let me ask you a question you're my
friend you make a lot of money yeah bro
don't ask you I'm gonna ask you on air
what I'm asking here off dude don't
please don't be I'm gonna ask you on air
and I'm being really serious I'm being
serious please don't do this
buy me an iPad Pro really yeah I know
much are they I don't get up
buy me an iPad Pro birthdays god I want
one and I don't want to spend the money
I don't know why no your likes I've been
giving a lot to charity lately $5,000
yeah that's excuse me I want a bigger
one I want the bigger come on just buy
it for me go come to with me and put it
on your credit card will you or won't
you sure buddy yeah there you go there
it is 870 now I want the one though with
don't be cheap about hey if you're gonna
call all right there let's do at twelve
point nine inch that's the one that is
the big boy I don't have a lot you down
over laptop or an iPad let's go buy one
let's go buy him after this I don't you
buy me one and you buy yourself one how
cool is that
that's a good deal I'll help you I'm not
gonna pay for it but I know you would
dig an iPad
what does use your phone mostly right
iPads just like I don't you know I don't
want the screen right you got to be on
it but you know what you can watch
movies one year I have a giant TV no but
when you're on the road get one and I'll
get one you are lights you can watch
documentaries inside i watch fight to
watch you disown let's go let's go
another screen we'll go after this you
buy yourself one get yourself a nice one
get me one into the [ __ ] of it cool you
make a lot of money man dude you make a
lot of money dude yeah but you have a
you're a CBD oil baron and i'm not say
Titan now I'm not gonna say Titan but
urinal you're a [ __ ] CBD baron you're
an oil baron you're an oil baron Oh what
else we I gave a lot to charity a lot to
charity this past [ __ ] three weeks
like too much it's embarrassing
but you know people need money and help
so I think I deserve an iPad as they buy
yourself one dude you just said you'd
buy one you just said you'd give me
$1,200 you know you know if we go buy a
store well wearing what we do that one
show together the end of the month no I
want one and sat in the cut for a long
this is new for Joe it wasn't until he
figured out a way to get his special on
Netflix by hook or crook by the way cuz
they kept saying no to him well he paid
for himself and there you go the other
thing is yeah
so whatever whatever you did but you
know what you know jo koy does too and I
do press now - he does so his shows are
all sold out everywhere sold out he
still does press
why do you press he is why wouldn't I
yeah so I'll take that too but I don't
like to impress I hate it i I do press
that I had to close my contract no press
just stuck jo koy I do press ma'am there
you go even when the shows it's just in
your approach it's called heavy go it's
called going wait that works you do that
I'm gonna do that yeah there's a huge
thing about copying successful people to
the ends degree I don't know why more
people don't do that just wouldn't you
watch what they're doing if it's working
for them just copy them that's what
Kevin Hart said that's what I do with
Dane Cook I'll watch Dane Cook I was
like I'm just gonna do that I'm gonna go
collect all the [ __ ] email address
Kevin at every one of his shows you have
somebody would walk around and get their
email addresses and he just had a bank
of amount of jo koy had I mean he wants
people to have like something physical
to take home with Liars like what's
flyers Wow
he I mean this is the way does merch if
you buy enough merch you get into the
VIP or you can just buy regular VIP it's
a whole experiment called by Marquez
press and he sold his whole thing was
proud to see me people after the show he
just does VIP and if you buy $75 more in
merch you get automatically getting VIP
Oh cuz he has so many shows you can't
can't become anything can you meet I
mean that's hard for him
oh yeah he's just seen those people he
does two shows a night uh yeah two shows
a night 16 shows yeah it's interesting
to be around him just see it I don't
know why they up to me that's that
stuff's priceless man to see how he does
a priceless I'm learning right now level
it's priceless did you watch the fights
well no
you didn't watch me that I didn't even
know they were on how about that
I was talking about on below the belt I
feel like they'll duh like the lust and
like the excitement for the UFC is just
not there anymore
I feel like wait he's not filming time
at this Todd's like dude I can tell you
is fighting anymore
what is the biggest fight you excited
about go I mean I'm looking forward to
this deep I fight no meet me - but
anything or a fight where you will stop
everything to have people over and watch
it's not there I would watch I would
john jones dcadt heavyweight trilogy
that that would be cool that's not
having them we don't have that that that
I'd watch and I want to see the first
Inca bead that would be very interesting
Connor coming back Chiron won't come
back will he I don't know but I'm just
saying now you know I don't want to see
kind of come back but I do want to see
like yeah we'd stop could be you'd have
people over khabib Ferguson that would
be amazed is nothing I'm saying like
stop enter Whitaker is I'm excited I'm
not gonna stop my plane right for it
right exact like I used to stop my life
with certain cards it's just I don't
know man and the ratings are kind of
saying what I'm saying yeah yeah I think
it goes back to having to you have to
create a story around you know your
fighters and they have to be yeah but
they've been around for years and
ratings are down so you know they're
doing it I just it's me coming out of a
bond not just coming out of a but look
that's you is that you just saying just
shook your hair out
and you're just like what your day
somebody said to you hey Jim you're
number one and you a la hey Jim you
never won you went huh or is that hey
man you forgot to put your pants on you
pants are off hey Jim Jim you got a dick
on you why yeah then you're going yeah
hey yeah look half you're going yeah you
look hidden look pleasantly surprised I
like I like the to the left in the
middle that's me going I might get a
roll somewhere you're sure that you're
great I look sexy tonight I might even
sexy it's time for me to start being
looked at as something a little
different than funny yeah
right there and if I'm casting a
therapist right there who's really
listening to me
that's the guy right there right right
before he says to me hey listen I've
been doing this a long time kill
yourself and you don't move your mouth
you guys kill yourself I look like I
really care about what you're saying
yep but inside you're going on hey did
they show you the Patriot yeah that's
better oh oh I clearly said yeah
absolutely think about you Jimmy said
you're super into aesthetics the one
thing about you is you're real detail
oriented about and controlling about
your image can we light up the top
please give me more light on my forehead
perfect that's the shot just go with it
it's kids go with that not lost a stitch
your hair at 52 and I've lost a lot of
mine and and you're you're not great to
look like Rainey tiny tiny bit is
starting to show up on this color no you
don't let it go not I'm doing killing
huh at the comic strip and Jim Jim
you're sensitive you're like me yes
supersenses well I mean because you're
earning most comics but Jim is Jim and
Jim is the world's a playground he's
doing stand-up it's a it's in New York
City he's crushing at the comedy I mean
crushing and there's a [ __ ] dude that
was my home yeah there's a dude and he's
just sitting there like that nothing
they have a friend I was watching his
face he's grown like this he's just cry
like this his mouth his openings like
this like he's about to go [ __ ] you
literally right you know the face before
you right before you go [ __ ] you like
yeah like hey [ __ ] you but not what
daddy's doing that
so finally Jim goes hey I got to stop
for a second is there a problem no way
and the guy goes you should say
something funny
oh so jim says water remember that Jim
goes but they're all laughing every I
remember you did this with your fingers
but everybody's laughing but you so he
goes yeah like that he goes okay keep
going
[ __ ] finally another three minutes
you're still not laughing I just don't
get this cuz you just look at me like
you're really pissed did I do something
to you and the guy goes I don't know you
should say something funny wow he's a
dick because Jim's looking at him and
you said something about a shirt and he
had like hair he's
guy who took his driving way too
seriously got a guy who wears [ __ ]
those those those moccasins where he had
long hair an open shirt just a [ __ ]
and with a chain and [ __ ] it [ __ ]
supreme and finally finally you go but I
want you to like me laughing laughing
dying no but this is the best because I
want you'd like this
yeah he's like he now he shuts up he's
just like looking at you like you're
still looking at me like that you're
still looking you come to a Comedy Store
you learn it's amazing he was and he
goes well I don't think you're funny and
then you go oh no buddy well now I'm
gonna have to go home and you've got up
on the stool and you rapped
you took the course Mel's like super
house huh and he just hangs there like
bangs and you're dying and you died I we
we were laughing so [ __ ] hard it was
a crazy thing everything I go do there's
a funny thing about you when you were
like what a dick he was such a dick
that's so mad at you I remember the hawk
hung yourself and it was the greatest
bit I've ever seen in my life that I
felt like such a tool to he was a tool
anyway so of course he did the Mach
hanging tomorrow my ember yeah mostly I
hung yourself is the greatest thing I've
ever seen on this tool I remember doing
nothing and you were going
my god and you kept making these from
high-pitched noises Wow I bet I used to
love playing there was a huge music guy
that owned this huge music company that
was retiring and I show up my god and it
was 12 people and it was a room a little
bigger than this and they were sitting
in two round tables and I had a just
stand there there's no microphone it
like yell from a soapbox
it was the most mortifying awkward and I
would try to talk to the guy it's not
engine it was you feel like a [ __ ] and
you're taking the check I have a buddy
good friend of ours don't say his name
but a big-time celebrities that came out
what you do 15 minutes of stand-up at my
wedding outside no he's like no man
that's not how to meet be a terrible
you're not be good you may be I'm not
and if it was funny yeah but you've
never done you actually 50 minutes of
stand-up and it's not the something
there's some there's some comics who are
beast at the corporate gig so it's just
summer and I feel it
I know Aziz I won't say who he went with
a friend of mine it's company that
brought in Aziz and then I came in he
can't say this this and this he was like
yeah cool went up there and just kind of
did his thing didn't go well he's like
give me my check I'm [ __ ] out of here
just go that's a thing you gotta realize
it's just a you know what this is gonna
pay for the kids going to college this
is gonna help with this speaks anymore I
don't want to read that last when he did
he sent me a video yeah I'm not doing
that [ __ ] it's a [ __ ] they were lawyers
and they got offended Ben did she came
up and scolded me in any but yeah and I
was like I'd be remit you could
definitely win them over remember I got
offered that corporate gig in
Jacksonville I called you but I'm
telling you do not do it now
I don't you look at them I feel like I'm
I feel like I'm being a [ __ ] it is and
I'm not doing it you're not say I will
never ever do stand-up where you tell me
I can't say certain things
go [ __ ] yourself here's my show right
here's myself go [ __ ] yourself know what
you're in the after the new you again
I do those I don't do things for money
that way hence the Dave Attell 30 times
while talking to you why wouldn't I give
that to you as it's a gif it's a gift
it's a gift